The joe rogan experience.
Wow.
This,
what year was this dear God,
I don't remember.
I've been having so much on it.
Yeah,
no,
you're great.
For a WHO's been hit in the head,
as many as you,
I never had a concussion.
I will say that we must have never had a concussion.
Wheeling.
Nope.
Well,
what does it concussion?
Concussion is like,
well,
they check your pupils.
They're not dialing correctly.
None of it.
None of them.
No concussions at all.
All that hard sparring.
Nope.
Never.
I find that hard to believe this.
He never got hit with a shot that they didn't see coming.
And I think that's never,
nope.
Nope.
Wow.
Besides one time in a huge fight where a dude hit me in the side of the head
with a brick and I saw it last second,
I at least rolled with it.
And that didn't give you a concussion?
He,
I,
he,
uh,
it was a huge bro.
It was hip hop night at the nightclub I was bouncing at.
Oh,
sounds like fun.
And the head and the Illinois Gang bangers and the Iowa gangbangers started
going at it.
And I tried breaking it up and they all attacked me,
right?
Jesus.
So that's when I,
everybody was wearing,
it was winter time.
So I was choking people.
A guy got me in a headlock and I was grabbing people by their coat lapels and I
hit my head in between his head and his head and I'd choke him unconscious.
I'd find a new coat and I was working my way backwards out the front door and
finally snuck out of the headlock,
put him in a rear choke,
went backwards off the door.
He went limp.
I dropped him.
And then as I turned to get out into the street,
cause there was cops everywhere at that point.
There's dogs,
it's a snow storm.
Last second.
I see this coming at the side of my head than I duck and it bounces off of my
head and this dude goes,
yeah,
like I was going to go down and I turned and I looked at him and rifle then with
a right hand and knocked him out.
And then the next thing you know there's just dogs diving into the crowd.
It was a good one.
And it was a fun one.
Dogs.
That's not good.
No.
Yeah.
The dogs work.
They work.
They work real well.
That's not good because they don't know who the fuck they're biting.
They might bite you.
They might bite the bad guys.
I mean,
who the fuck dogs don't know who the bouncer is?
Clear crowd out real quick.
Fuck yeah,
they do.
Now Moz,
is that all you're using a back then it was shepherds real.
It was all German.
Shepard j a melon was hadn't even entered the scene at that time.
I have a buddy who trains dogs who doesn't like Mel.
It says there are two blood thirsty.
He said they were aggressive.
Yeah.
He goes,
they don't listen as well.
Interesting.
He goes,
he goes,
I can trust the shepherd.
He goes,
bite,
hold and release.
Yeah.
He's like,
if I stick a Malmo on and it goes through the fuck knows.
He goes also,
I don't trust him like as a pet.
Right.
You know he wants a dog.
That is is a real train bite dog,
but also good with the family.
Yeah.
I can hang out with your kid.
Right.
Well,
that's like I iPhone mastiffs before,
right?
And massive mass stuff there.
You know,
I had brindle mastiff and I always love to have males and I had a stalker for
three years who was a psychopath,
right?
So that was when I got my first mass duff king.
He was 210 pounds,
but he was a brindle.
Scary look like a Bengal tiger.
Right?
And he that those dogs are so powerful,
you know,
at that size when they're truly in shape where you can't stop them.
And there were people that were using mastiffs for police work and they stopped
using them because a 210 pound mass mastiff on a human being,
they can kill them really fast.
This is not a,
this is not a bite dog.
This is a dog that can just have a screw,
go loose and rip somebody,
throw it out in a heartbeat.
It's just too big and tall.
AFFEC hurts him if something hurts him and they think,
oh,
this is a fight,
right?
I'm just going to rip your fucking head clean off your body.
Right.
And that massive tested me a couple of times.
Ooh,
for Alpha position in the house.
Oh No.
It was one time up,
a plastic bag in the wind was rolling through the woods and on my property.
And he ran and he grabbed it and I told him,
you know,
King come here front.
And it came up to me and I put my hand on the plastic bag and he goes,
hey,
sorry.
Alright,
here it is.
This is,
this is test time.
So I ripped the bag and it came out of his mouth right.
And he really got pissed off at me.
I was testing them.
So at that point I'm like,
well I can't back down to it now.
This is it.
So I put my fist against his teeth that he was showing and I was going do it
Joe.
It sees this Christ do it.
And he's like this with his teeth going,
I'm going to Joe it,
Joe it.
And finally he turned and backed off and then I pet him and he was wagging his
tail and I was like,
all right.
Ooh,
that was,
that was kind of scary.
Ryan Parsons got in a fist fight with his massive.
Really?
Yeah.
He had a Neapolitan mastiff in college.
They got in a fistfight.
He goes,
it was a real fight.
And he goes,
I had a fight with my mom.
I'm like,
maybe.
Maybe he did.
More likely you punched your mastiff cause it was a real fight.
I wouldn't be talking to you may be chunks missing out.
Yeah,
you'd be fucking dead.
I'm Neapolitan.
That's a giant fucking dog.
Yeah.